I mean dude what see the thing is I've
been I'm 53 man you know I'm getting
close to Heaven than anybody you know
getting close to Heaven every day so I
want to understand because there's that
life you know because I said I mean this
stuff this is breaking news right here I
didn't even tell it's a comedy hype I
mean I got 10 more years in this comedy
game huh yeah I got about 12 more years
in the comedy game I'm retiring I'm
gonna be a minister what
why 12
well I'll be 65. oh you're catching
retirement like you're a teacher or
something I understand I'm going right
I'm gonna go start and if I say one so
that's all I need you know I just I owe
God that was because he blessed me to
make a living
doing something
we're telling jokes I'm not giving that
no product or nothing I'm telling Jose
and making a great living there and I
don't won't reward him with a soul or
something that I could give back to
yeah like when I started comedy I was
about to graduate college and then I
prayed on was like do I need to follow
this degree in business or do I need to
follow like this comedy thing I've been
always wanting to do and I prayed on it
and like woke up the next day like oh
I'm gonna go do comedy but I haven't
really yeah I Feel Like Show Business
you're doing business you doing yeah
yeah that's true I just I just haven't I
guess given back in a way like like
you're saying you want to like give back
I haven't really always you well see you
pay your tithes and offering that's
giving back take that 20 000 give this
load out of that 200. and you know that
that's all it is he don't ask for much
okay that don't bother you about
something guys that story The Prodigal
Son you remember the guy he gave all his
riches to his first son he took it and
he left when party kicked in there thing
and wind up being broke after you spend
all his money eating with swine came
back and apologized his father and said
hey man I'll be a slave just let me come
back home be a slave that's why I said
you ain't gonna you know say you my son
player bring out my fattest calf my son
has returned to me and the thing about
that what they're telling you guys say
you don't matter what you've done
I'll forgive you and let you come back
it's nothing you can do unless you
commit suicide where you can you know
you dead you hear it and I gotta you
gotta go I'm sorry you I could have
saved you but otherwise than that he
understands boom yeah he understands
that means dude we this game is physical
but you know you get that 10 and thinker
man it just don't turn away from them
okay and so it's simple man and like I
said man I don't I'm not gonna ever sell
my soul for for video Fame you know what
I'm saying because see you look at Dave
Chris you look at Kev
those guys and I ain't saying they said
they so don't get me wrong
Tiffany has they always in the eye
everybody looking at them I'm in the eye
a lot it seemed like sometimes it turned
up louder sometimes it turns down but I
can't go a lot of places without being
recognized I'll get recognized oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God I gotta
get off the plane in uh Newburgh New
Jersey 50 students came from Atlanta
from a business conventionally was just
here and they saw me and one kid walks
over the you know the the representative
and he said excuse me anybody said you
look like you from Breaking Bad I said
yeah well I guess because I am here you
are kid freak all white kids too hey oh
my God oh my God man they surrounded and
then it became a q a taking pictures of
the photo op it was incredible it was
wonderful
you know and I mean and the thing about
it is I I can't believe I didn't even
have many lives I think if you count all
my episodes of Breaking Bad I got 10
lines but you're Unforgettable people
see you like they don't forget yeah I
guess so so so but in that I realized
how much God has blessed me man and I
mean dude me from daily Joe's I'm on a
drama
a big probably the biggest TV show that
ever exists beside The Sopranos yeah for
real people been talking about bringing
back and it's been over for how long
they did a little movie and it wasn't
even about breaking bad it was about
Jesse uh so
so in in that aspect I look at man you
know you asked me like do I think I'm
sure I I know I am I can't
I can't get what I think is Success like
you say 10 years I can't get what I
think is success but I know I am
successful and and the thing about I I
can't take away from that is to have
stopped lying to myself there man I'm
ultimately blessed I got everybody on
play Road my family I'm taking care of
everybody I've you know
uh my son is healthy he lives a life
where he buys tennis shoes off of a
fight club or two grand and little kid
and he I mean he walking I could give
what I want when I want it you know so
my to a limit but you know I I know that
I am
it blessed and I know that I am
successful and so when you like you said
I can't have I have a lot of
expectations you know and don't get
wrong you always want to you have
expectancy but you don't put it on
yourself because you're gonna get that
you write out your prayer book or write
out your
uh put up your uh vision board and just
say where the heck you want to go what
you want to do
and you know and I think God gives it to
you when you're ready boom you know
because you may get all that success and
you married okay so you may lead your
way no no no no no no no no no no no no
don't listen babe don't listen honey no
no no I'm not saying no I'm just saying
before you ready oh no before you got a
kid no okay yeah I ain't saying you're
gonna leave your way I said before you
ready you see because that's the thing
about it when you ever seen crashing
with Pete Holmes yeah yeah
look at this this whole story it's vice
versa she left him but think about it
you know his life started changing and
metamorphosizing it's just a thing about
life Builds on his own you go you're
gonna look up you watch you're gonna
look up and next thing you know you you
you're gonna be in every Club around the
country
I watch
I mean you got the faith you got you got
the faith you can you could probably do
the Ted Bundy Story I mean I had the
face this face ain't what it's about
anymore this whole too white to fail
face
you still got it I mean I appreciate it
like you look at Gary Owens right I mean
Gary Gary he he reached this levels but
Gary non-stop he keep going he keeps
going people his tenacity is what make
him they didn't think that he do black
Club Gary goes hard for sure all the
time on that stage he don't play yeah
yeah yeah and I can't take that away
from him even though I talk about his
ass man I I can't take that away from
him and I gotta respect him this clip is
one of hundreds we have here at hot
breath so click right here to subscribe
and check them out and then jump to this
video I picked just for you
sorry about the eyebrows